hello everyone this is emily here from
audio science review
today i have a speaker review for you a
uh
powered monitor um from krk systems
called rocket five generation four i
guess
there's been three other generations
um they all have this trademark
yellow cone and i don't think their
twitters used to be yellow but
now they're yellow uh cute looking thing
i like the way it looks i think some
people don't like it but
i'm cool with it i don't know if you can
see it's got a little wave guide in here
i've explained my last video
uh that uh at crossover region the uh
woofer beam width can narrow and if you
just hand it off directly to the twitter
the twitter is too wide at that point
and you get a step response
in off axis which is not good so nice to
see a
waveguide around there it's a powered
speaker
so you need to plug it into mains
on off switch a rather crude
black and white lcd but actually is
quite legible compared to even high-end
jbl
speakers that have a really horrible
display in here
easy to navigate the menus they also
have an app that lets you
calibrate it it's got a graphic
equalizer not a parametric one
if you don't know the difference maybe
i'll explain it one day but it's
certainly better than nothing
um the sole input is balanced
either with trs or xlr cable and
tested with xlr cable
there is a front port
this is so that you can put them against
the wall and not worry about
a port being in the back that's blocked
so rest of the features you can go
online and look
i'm here to tell you how it performs
so let's look at the review on audio
science review website
i will put a link to it so you can find
it let me organize my
windows here a little bit all right
um it's the wave guide that i talked
about a close-up shot of it
as usual the measurements that you're
about to see
are with this really fancy clippable
near-field scanner that i use
that's robotic system that scans all the
way around the speaker
and it's able to eliminate room noise
and
room reflection so even though i don't
have an anechoic chamber
it gives you a measurement two
measurements of the speaker independent
of the room
which is what we want skin colder so
temperature for the measurement was 63.
i mentioned that because a couple of
monitors i've tested
are sensitive to temperature and the
colder it gets their base
goes down by a db or so how sensitive
these are i don't know i don't think
it's critical but it's winter time here
and
even though i heated up the lab space it
was
it was only 63 degrees fahrenheit
um looking at the frequency response the
first thing i always look at is this on
axis black graph which is the top over
here
and at first looks like it's kind of
jagged it goes up and down
here some anomalies here and then the
dragon doesn't see her then it goes up
and it comes down
but remember these are not electronics
measurements
uh these are electromagnetic
measurements and
uh i mean electromechanical measurements
so you're never going to see
extremely rude or flat response except
for some high-end dsp monitors
and so if you step back you actually you
know the
on axis looks pretty flat i mean if you
look from here to there
and just eyeball a horizontal line it's
more or less flats yes there's a dip in
here and there's a rise before it
there's a little weirdness over here
but again not a major issue
one other thing then i look over here is
this uh
directivity index and i see that it's
quite smooth
uh yes it goes down a little bit in here
so the crossover is not perfect but
it's pretty good until it gets to way
out here
where the speaker then gets directional
and that's okay
because that's just extreme highs and we
don't hear that that well
you can see why over here you see the
response here drops off
we're curious what the cause of this
little anomaly is
i take a microphone and i'm making
measurements right in front of twitter
right in front of the
woofer right in front of the port and
you get these three graphs in here
this is the woofer in red it's got the
natural bass response and stuff to roll
off
actually that's pretty good response the
twitter is in blue
this is the real part of it this part is
not correct the microphone when it's up
here still picks up the bass so
ignore that response below one and a
half kilohertz
um we see that twitter is kind of uneven
it goes up and down and that's the
reason on the
previous graph we didn't see a smooth
response in a twitter
but the because of that notch that we
were looking at up here
is actually resonance in uh port
over here and the resonance could be out
of phase and in this case it indeed is
and it causes this uh the base response
to cancel out
um you know ideally the port response
would go way down here would be much
more attenuated
but you know in a 179 dollar speaker you
can't expect perfection in there so you
get a little bit of notch
um so pretty predictable you can see how
graphs tells a lot
you know two different measurements two
different approaches both of them
sort of back each other up which is nice
for far field use which doesn't quite
apply to a monitor
though somewhat does we look at all
these different measurements floor
ceiling
front and back walls rear wheels rear
walls
and total reflections and that's the sum
of these
we see that the you know the anomaly
that we had there is still there but
ignoring that we see that there's a bit
of a dip in the
one to three kilohertz uh that's if you
look at what contributes the most to it
is the blue line
which is the floor bounce and this dash
red line which is the ceiling this is
pretty typical
both in home loosening systems and in
monitors
and my recommendation most of the time
is to absorb the floor reflections and
the ceiling is
you know you could absorb them because
in the studio at home is harder but if
you can get a tall ceiling
you know distance is also your friend
and
if you do that then this dip won't be as
pronounced as as it looks over here
the highs you know they go up a little
bit and then drop off
whether that bounces out is up to your
taste
a good amount of base in here we have
base down to
20 30 40 50 hurts or so so
pretty healthy amount of bass in there
for file for far field listening
we can predict the response by putting
the last two graphs together and we get
basically what we expected dipped
in the mid range in the lower treble
that we've already noted
this little notch in here a bit of
unevenness in the twitter all of that is
what we could have already predicted but
it's good to have it compositor put
together
uh extremely good news here um if you
look at the red line it says if we take
a six decibel drop off
and uh look at it based on frequency
what does it look like and
we'll see that it's almost you know as
speakers go flat
uh between some like seven eight hundred
hertz all the way up to up to above 10
kilos
this is extremely good and it's very
wide too plus or minus 70 degrees so
what this means is that
you can move around fair bit to the left
and right of the speaker and the
tonality will not shift
and that's also great in that the
reflections that are coming
from the side and hitting the side walls
have the similar tonality to the on axis
which means that they just reinforce
each other and don't have a negative
effect they don't
cause tonality shifts towards the end
all
sudden the twitter becomes very
directional
as the wavelengths get small relative to
his size
the directivity narrows we call that
beaming
but that's okay it's just a little bit
less highs
where some of us can't hear it anyway
and those that here would probably think
is annoying to hear
too much of it or fatigue and sound if
you will so
this is quite nice this is above class
performance above what i would expect in
in a budget speaker we can look at that
in a contoured display
basically it's a 3d graph expressed as a
2d graph
and we can see the same kind of
smoothness of a response over here
and then sudden drop so this graph is
really a duplicate of the
one above it just different presentation
of it
vertically as you move around
vertically up and down the speaker the
timing difference between these two
drivers
varies so in the crossover region how
they mix changes a lot so as a result
when we go up or we go down we see that
the uh
we have drops in the frequency response
as indicated by the color going from red
to
green and blue if you will so you don't
want to go
in those regions you want to stay within
this sweet spot if you will the line is
at the twitter center
so if you sit have this speaker pointed
at you vertically
you know if it's sitting at your ear
level then it's fine if it's up higher
point it down
so that you're hearing the direct on
access sound
if you can't you still have uh 20 30
degrees above so this can be below your
ear level as it is right now for me
is fine you can go a hair below maybe
5 or 10 degrees but not much more if you
go further down
you'll hit this ditch in here so you get
a deficiency basically around
two to three killers very very audible
in that region so you don't want to do
that
these waterfall displays i've mentioned
they're problematic because i can tweak
them to show anything you want
i have adjusted this one to more or less
show reasonable information we can see
that this is our original frequency
response and there's a
resonance that keeps going it means we
activate it once and it goes
by itself and this is that port
resonance that's coming out of here that
we mentioned earlier with that notch so
that's very predominantly
visible we also see other resonances at
these other frequencies
i haven't bothered tracing them their
effect was pretty small
could be a cabinet resonating could be a
driver
it could be anything and
so it tells you something but if you
look in here is the clue as to why we
don't need this most of the time you see
this
resonance here if you go all the way
back what do you see up here
you see a peak there so usually the
peaks are where the resonances are
anyway
so we could mostly predict this you can
see there's a peak here and there's a
resonance here speaker resonance so
most of the time it doesn't tell us
anything we don't know
uh frequency response is most important
but once we get that
out of the way we want to see how much
distortion we have and i'll test the
distortion at
86 db at the decibels of
one meter and then 96 db or 10 db higher
at 86 db it actually does quite well um
yes there's distortion one or two
percent but at low frequencies
above a few hundred hertz is actually
below half a percent which is
very good and so definitely usable at
86 db at 96 db these little guys usually
run out of amplification power run out
of woofer range or both
and you can see in this case the woofers
and the amplifier and the combination of
gun nuts
uh just there's nothing usable here
you've got immense amount of distortion
the twitter is still okay and it just
it doesn't need as much power it doesn't
move as much so it's still happy but
woofer is always the limitation in these
uh
in any reasonable size bookshelf speaker
and this is a quite small
low-cost one kind of unfair to take the
960b
and plot it this way but that's my
standard so if we take our 960v
graph and instead of a percentage we
look at the absolute distortion we see
that the absolute distortion
over here actually crosses over our
actual response of the speaker
that means that we actually have more
distortion than we have
the original tone so clearly at 96 db
this is blowing his brains out
at 30 40 hertz so one thing you could do
is roll this off
if you have an eq you can put a high
pass system a high pass filter here and
add a sub if you like um i'll talk about
my listening test in a second
i didn't have to do that for the way
this got distorted
was fine but we can see that with this
50 db threshold that i pick
as my standard it's exceeding it across
the board almost
so it's really not a good speaker to use
for
that level of volume
i have a strict set of
test tracks that i use i always always
always start with the same tracks
so the tracks are the same speakers are
put in the same position
so everything is static from test to
test to test i don't take every speaker
and reposition them and create a new
environment that's not
comparable to the last one and because i
always use the same tracks listen to the
same thing
it helps the subjective aspect of a
review to be more reliable
than it would be by just randomly
placing these things and playing
whatever music
like that they uh it's the same music
i'm sick of listening to them
but for the sake of that stick that's
what i do they're female
reference tracks or tracks actually if
you go to shows i play them
so their tracks are supposed to sound
beautiful and if they don't sound
beautiful then you know you're in
trouble
and on this speaker they did i mean a
lot of speakers are tests and instantly
i hear
they don't sound good this one first 10
seconds was great
and if the speakers too bright after 10
seconds usually i get sick of them
this wasn't the case it is a studio
monitor
and they tend to be a little bit have
elevated highs
and i accept that as as the equation if
you're doing this kind of mixing
and mastering or even at amateur level
it's fine to have a little bit higher
eyes you can just
position them a little bit off axis and
that gets less if you want but i didn't
feel like i needed to do anything
for kicks i went and put a a little
notch filter in here to get rid of this
resonance that we had over here this uh
peaking in here you see this peak is at
680 hertz
and my experience is that when you take
that down usually improves
detail and resolution tonality doesn't
change because it's so narrow our
hearing
doesn't pick that up and then i had the
same experience i had with this one the
sound gets a little
warmer why does it get a little warmer
because i think there's less distortion
going on there because you're reducing
the amount of
basically what this will for us to play
so it actually naturally reduces
distortion
and it was extra amplitude we didn't
need anyway
and i thought it made a subtle but
useful improvement
but i'll warn you that this is
subjective it could be placebo i
could be expecting it to sound good with
that filter even though i wasn't sure i
thought it wouldn't make a difference
it did it's a very narrow thing so if
you have this speaker i'll be interested
in
you trying it and let me know it's a
parametric eq the frequency is 680 hertz
four decibels uh db i brought it down
and
q the sixes so it's quite high and the q
makes the filter narrow uh on this thing
as soon as i plugged this in i sat back
and enjoyed the sound i mean i in the
window i have
far fancier audio system i could listen
to i didn't want to stop listening to
this guy
uh it's very nice um
turn it up and then and the bass gets
distorted in a subtle way but
you know sort of i don't know it doesn't
make it better in sound but you can
feel here that the bass becomes is not
as clean
and as you turn it up it linearly gets
worse some speakers are fine and all of
a sudden they crackle which i hate
they're kind of scary you think
that the speaker is going to blow this
one's not it it just the bass gets
the the bass notes get more distorted in
a very obvious way
and uh just turn it down when that
happens
i only test one speaker because research
shows that you can test
uh uh you can detect flaws in a speaker
far better when there's one and there's
the second one masking it or
creating the stereo image which can fool
you make you think the sound is better
than it really is
but the downside is that one speaker
doesn't get as loud as two speakers
so i think two speakers you'll have
plenty of volume for desktop use it'll
blow away any of the crappy pc speakers
and multimedia speakers
it's just the proper monitor
and produces good sound now one problem
with all these things a lot of them
use these class d amps that are quite
noisy and
you can hear the hissing from the
twitter sometimes two or three feet away
the jbl's are famous for that
but some of the other pro monitors are
the same way too although i should say
most of them are
this one i couldn't i could hear barely
hear a hiss out of it at one or two
inches
and uh when i came further back
i just couldn't hear it now i have a
slight wind from my pc and that dwarfs
it
but then again i've tested other power
monitors in the same setup it takes a
foot or more
for me to not hear it um this kind of
hiss though sometimes they're speaker
dependent
and uh gain dependent i've tested this
at factory setting with 0db gain so
um your environment may differ but
take this as a hint that this was
potentially his free
uh you know first practical listening
which is a big deal
uh if if that pans out so
i was tempted to give this speaker my
highest rating
but the fact that he gets distorted when
he turn it up um
you know it it just and a couple of port
resonances and so forth i want to leave
room for a speaker that
doesn't have those two limitations so i
brought it down but i really really like
the speaker
um i went in thinking oh it's just a
popular speaker
you know typical speaker the youtuber
loves to
rave about that you know has no
experience evaluating these kinds of
things critically
but uh both the measurements and and
objective measurements of my listening
tests say hey
competently designed according to the
science they go into
research i go into engineering and you
know they made the right trade-offs to
get a
pretty looking system with dsp apps that
control it and
uh you know job well done uh you know
it's hard
as picky as i am i couldn't find
anything else wrong with it so
um suggest putting that on your shopping
list and if you want to know what good
sound is like and
uh got 170 dollars get a single one
listen to it get it from amazon you can
return if you don't like it
and if you're in us and give it a try
it's
it's a good speaker okay
that's it i see you in the next video
bye-bye